[Musique]
atlanta le berceau des droits civiques
aux états unis
[Musique]
cette ville d'à peine 500 mille
habitants a vu naître martin luther king
le symbole même du mouvement pacifiste
des années 60
à l'aube d'une élection aussi polarisé
les mots du révérend en orange jamais
raisonné aussi fort et les votes des
afro-américains jamais aussi important
[Musique]
il est notre inspiration à tous du
rwanda mosely militant auprès du
mouvement black blues mars les électeurs
noirs compte l'objectif s'assurer que
les afro américains aillent aux urnes le
3 novembre
pas question de faire du porte-à-porte
qu'ovide oblige c'est désormais à la
sortie de centres d'achat qu'on tente
d'inscrire les électeurs
l'application et sur chaque véhicule
il suffit de la télécharger avec son
cellulaire une élection cruciale pour
team du web qui arbore un triste ce
slogan faisant référence aux jeunes
afro-américains mort sous les balles de
policiers blancs dans notre champ perçu
ici comme un président raciste
[Musique]
mais c'est surtout dans les petites
communautés qu'il faut aller chercher
les électeurs souvent oubliés comme ici
à warner bros
à 2h d'atlanta en 2010 8 750 mille
électeurs n'avaient pas été inscrits et
la majorité était des afro américains
on ne veut pas répéter la même erreur il
constitue 33 % de l'électorat et vote à
96 % pour les démocrates et donne le
champion ne veut pas de leur vote
[Musique]
ici un mécano coeur de la géorgie on
profite de la distribution de paniers
alimentaires pour installer les bureaux
[Musique]
chaque boîte peut nourrir une famille de
quatre pendant sept jours
la file est longue
les militants de blagues vaseuses mature
profit de la tente et s'active
[Musique]
s'inscrire si la première barrière à
franchir pour faire valoir son droit de
vote
chez nous au maroc et en plus c'est à la
discrétion de l'employeur d'allouer du
temps pour aller voter
autant d'obstacles pour que les banques
en sorte qu'ils considèrent que
l'amérique de trump est un retour en
arrière
un deuxième mandat le fait frémir et
c'était il n'ya pas si longtemps
[Musique]
près de soixante ans plus tard le combat
pour l'égalité raciale continue aux
etats-unis
une mobilisation qui elle espère se
reflétera dans le taux de participation
des électeurs qui auront le choix entre
deux amériques